[Musique]
salut à tous pour commencer cette vidéo
je vais restaurer le pistolet le
français modèle policeman péché lors de
la précédente vidéo
ensuite je retourne au hotspot pour
chercher les 13 restants
voici donc l'état du pistolet quand je
vais sortir de l'eau j'ai heureusement
directement pensé à mettre du wd 40
dessus afin d'éviter qu'ils ne roulent
davantage à cause du changement de
milieu
donc là j'ai fini d'enlever tout ce qui
est révélateur du chargeur donc on peut
voir qu'avec
le temps qu'il a passé sous l'eau le
chargeur a été totalement détruits avait
carrément de la vase à l'intérieur où
j'ai sorti cette vase il reste que les
ressorts du chargeur donc là ce qui me
reste à faire
ce côté on voit que la vie c'est les
bonnes je pourrais l'utiliser pour
accrocher mon ma protection en bois et
de l'autre côté je vais essayer de
sortir la vis
donc voilà le résultat après nettoyage
j'ai fait le choix de ne pas utiliser de
solutions de décapante et de le faire
uniquement avec le double des 40 en
frottant les détails qui m'intéressait
le plus bien que ce soit plus long
davantage sait par exemple que je peux
garder le bouchon intacte je pense qu'il
serait moins bien ressortir en enlevant
la rouille là au moins il est en entier
voilà donc on peut rien des montées bien
sûr est vraiment trop abîmer la gâchette
à ressort plutôt bien sympathique
il ya juste la protection tout autour
qui est cassé
c'est pas grave ça ressort quand même
bien bon on peut même pas sortir le
chargeur c'est totalement tour où il ya
l'intérieur et ça casserait le canon il
est obstruée on va pas chercher à
frotter non plus de toute manière il
ressort très bien de l'extérieur ça me
suffit ici on peut voir qui est écrit
fabrication sûrement le début de
fabrication france donc maintenant je
vais m'attaquer à la fabrication de ma
plaquette qui servira le mettre en
vitrine et le rendre plus beau je fais
un patron pour ma plaquette je fais
quelque chose de plutôt grand que je
réagisse au fur et à mesure voilà j'ai
choisi un bois qui était un bois flotté
parce que il al'avantage d'être
facilement coupable en deux et ce sera
facile à faire j'ai pas besoin d'un bois
trop résistants de toute manière vu que
chez les pros de la déco donc là je vais
dessiner avec mon stylo la forme et je
vais attaquer le découpage à lahti
[Rires]
[Musique]
je pense simplement de ce petit lame de
couteau que j'ai péché pour le séparer
en deux
j
points à la une plaquette à convaincre
donc maintenant j'ai fait les marques
sur le bois que je vais découper au
couteau
donc ce que je vais faire maintenant
c'est que je vais préparer la vis pour
attacher pour le marquage utilise une
mine du critérium qui va me permettre de
passer dans les deux trous à faire une
marque en face et ensuite j'aurai juste
à percer avec la petite vis donc
maintenant on va penser cette petite
cross avec du papier de verre
donc voici ma plaquette une fois bien
pensé
donc c'est normal qu'ils avaient des
aspérités puisque c'est un bois flottés
je vous rappelle et le but c'est de
rester dans l'ambiance avec le pistolet
qui a passé des années sous l'eau voilà
donc ma plaquette une fois la cire
passer dessus tout brillante
on va donc la place et voilà ajouter la
petite vis
j'ai donc choisi une vis de couleur
noire pour qu'elle aille avec le
pistolet et voilà le pistolet est prêt
il peut donc rejoindre la vitrine avec
les autres trouvailles de pêche aliments
et rendez vous maintenant au spot où on
a trouvé
[Applaudissements]
l'ancien skieur grosses pierres voilà
j'ai déjà fait tout est parti là bas
bien terminer à issy las des trucs âgées
quelque chose de gros là quelques kilos
où j'ai peut-être même deux trucs aux
[ __ ] d'accord ok en effet quelques
kilos à 17 moule et moules du canal du
milieu rennais mouassa pas beau ça
bon petite cuillère j'en fais une par
croteau tiens
donc pas de soucis
[Musique]
bliss vous aide ouais c'est bon sommes
pas trop bien
ouais c'est ça
non les troènes en général on garde il
ya que leur sérail on vend aux
ferrailleurs simplement
et sinon je garde tout en vitrine ça a
cool ouais ouais voilà ce à quoi
allez bonne journée
bon bah c'est pas pour me la péter mais
c'est la première fois que quelqu'un dit
qu'il connaît notre chaîne youtube nous
a pas dit s'ils étaient abonnés mais en
tout cas il a dit qu'ils connaissent et
notre chaîne et ça ça fait toujours
plaisir
this way la boule de pétanque ça c'est
pas une grenade
c'est juste que il ya un petit truc qui
est attiré par le beast à travers la
boule est seul à la limite
utilisable mais hors limites à sa tante
un je pense
aïe aïe aïe à la presse cheikh hamad à
c'est dommage parce que si c'est ce que
c'est que ce truc
à sa tête un bijou ah bon vous en faire
encore quelque chose oh oui le marteau
alpha mos
bon voila j'ai à peu près tout fait sur
cette partie